you're referring to the minimum genome
project and also synthetic synthetic
life when you talk about now the
synthetic biology is just small small
elements a little little bits of gene
function then that's that they do a
particular thing you're talking about an
entire organization study genomics is a
either a subset of synthetic biology or
synthetic biology is a subset of that
it's not clear dependent who you're
talking to but we're dealing with making
the entire genome out of starting with
the digital code in the computer in fact
we just finished designing three
different versions of a minimal genome
that we're about to do the transplants
and find out if they work it's the first
time we've designed an entire genome in
the computer but it's hard to do because
there's still a lot of biology that's
unknown so what you're talking about is
designing something computer I've been
synthesizing it in DNA then injecting
the DNA into a empty cell original well
it's actually not empty as a recipient
cell what happens as soon as you put the
new DNA in the cell within seconds it
starts to get red you know just how our
protein robots work you know they
recognize the DNA they blind to it they
start copying it and the proteins start
getting made and some of the early
proteins that get made are the
restriction enzymes that my colleague
cam Smith discovered and got the Nobel
Prize for in 1978 so he's 81 and still
working at the bench every day it's a
great role model for young scientists
but anyway these restriction enzymes
recognize the chromosome in the cell as
foreign DNA and chew it up so we start
with the body of one species and the
genetic software of another and within a
very short period of time the genetic
software replaces everything in the cell
with proteins made from its instructions
in a short while we have a new cell
based on that new genetic software and
there's not a single molecule left from
the original species so you completely
convert one species into another simply
by replacing the software you know Mac
users wishes
you could do that just by replacing the
software and a pc right indeed so then
when you say boot up that's that's what
you mean yeah how close to that are we
well we can do it we did it with the
first synthetic chromosome that was
largely modeled off an existing
chromosome we made a number of changes
the team devised a whole new code so we
can write the entire English language
with numbers and punctuation we put in
some quotations and things like that so
to prove that it's synthetic we've made
these three chromosomes and so if it
works people will know about it soon
okay if it doesn't you won't hear
anything what does it go back to the
bench and try another version